[Music]
there may be a 99 arm accuracy on the
line here no pressure this is what i've
been waiting for
[Music]
what is up and welcome to underrated the
number one show to improve athletes
video game ratings behind me in the box
nolan arenado yes eight-time gold glover
and just
he just smashes the ball but we need to
know how he is in the show that's why we
got our pro gamer ashley sanders to
break it down
nolan aronado one of the best third
baseman in recent mlb history when it
comes to his bat he can do it all
whether it's contact power driving in
some runs no one is your guy so of
course when it comes to attributes like
bunting nolan arenado is definitely
underrated do you know what your bunt
rating is in the show
um i i don't 35 35
what's the highest on a bunny rating
probably 99.
wow that is low i need your ratings in
the show
for this next generation yeah to be
blown away yeah and i have a guy that's
going to help us get it there all right
let's do it we're going to bring in
ramone i'm not even gonna look at him
he's just coming in he's gonna hit her
in the back what's happening what's
going on man you heard him talking about
the ratings i want to start off with an
easy one his bunt rating right how can
we take this to the next level and why
is he at a 35 well because he doesn't
bunt
he doesn't butt but you've got you got a
hundred on power versus lefties 99
fielding 99 arm not a lot of players in
the game have not yet but you know
everything matters you never know when
you might have to lay down that butt so
there's nothing better than trying to do
it so what we've laid out here three
targets if you get it in that initial
white or that back blue that's one point
the sweet spots that middle red for two
points anything else is minus one and
ramon correct me if i'm wrong
with 10 attempts he could go up 20
points you could and that might take you
up past a 90 overall so who knew that
your butt rating could be the thing that
takes you faster
how does that make you feel it makes me
feel really good it makes me i really
want to lay these down yes i got this
it's bud time let's go
all right nolan let's lay down some buns
start off on the first base line
whenever you're ready
that's a beauty get in there hold on
hold on there one day it's the first one
i think it's a one
i want to give you the two but i think
it's a one that's a one hand i gotta be
honest
good
exact spot wow okay
that right there is picture perfect
that's in there that's in there that's
two
that's gotta go slow grass so
two four five six seven your plus seven
that means if you hit all of these into
the twos we can get up to plus 17. it's
on you hold it down nolan
all right third base line
stay fair no
oh my that's a foul it's minus one
okay deep rest minus two it's okay the
grass is a little high
get through oh man
that's on the line it's on the line and
it counts
yes and there it is that's the money
shot and now the final throw
he's got the grass can we do the five
now cause he's got it down bam
beautiful i'll take it all right we went
plus seven on the right
we went plus three on the left that's a
plus ten yeah
moving in from a 35 to a 45
and you're happy to give those points
happy happy to give though because you
watched it happen we watched it happen
and the grass wasn't on his side plus
then how does that feel feels pretty
good i had some close calls um
pepe throw her through great right there
and i let him down a little bit but uh
wow i gotta be better team players
unbelievable
eight-time gold glove winner and when
you look at his stats they match that
his fielding his arm strength his
reaction all of them are top-notch for
one of the best defensive cards in the
game
however his arm accuracy is simply just
not up to par with those other defensive
attributes which definitely makes him
underrated in that stat category
[Applause]
[Music]
a little birdie told me that the arm
accuracy is a little bit lower than that
it's a little low i mean 99 that's yeah
that's like perfect so arm accuracy is
like a 75
75 which is great i heard that through
the cough yeah i know i feel like my
actor's okay i have had my first
baseman's they've had to make some good
plays for me there's no doubt it's true
they've had to scoop up a lot of balls
for me there's no question stop being a
good teammate
but but it's ridiculous that he's a 75
but i feel like i could be higher than
that okay because you said that your
first baseman's have saved you i'm gonna
be your first baseman
kind of
and i've got a big glove to make some
big saves
this is your time
to show us all the goods yeah we're
gonna hit some balls to get down at your
beautiful hot corner of the third base
and i want you to hit the target you
ready to do this i'm ready to do it
let's do it ramone let's go take a look
okay no lin you got this brother ready
oh man i actually think it's harder to
hit the pole than it is
whips it
wow
i hit his head i got his head
[Music]
let's up the ante okay what are you
thinking you're already
plus 15 maybe 20. okay
if you can hit
the small glove
there may be a 99 arm accuracy on the
line here wow no pressure
this is what i've been waiting for
that's it 99 arm accuracy 99 fielding
and 99 armstrong wow but no pressure
in the world of sports video games there
is no number more revered than 99 and
that is on the line that is on the line
how many throws does he get all right i
can't get in five i don't deserve it all
right let's get it a 99 on the line 99
arm accuracy is on the line
[Music]
round two
oh
[Music]
my gosh like
12 inches too low
no
[Music]
there it is oh
last one last one okay all right hold on
hold on i don't get it undeserved take
it come on
here it is all right last one ready for
99 feeling five
[Music]
no way
i thought that went between my face and
the glove i think it did
it's okay it's okay
this is why oh my god this is why i
appreciate nolan
what i'm feeling the energy out of you
right now is you're a little bit
disappointed we went into that final
throw plus 15 so he's a 90 arm accuracy
what is this going to do to his overall
rating probably going to bump him to a
90.
how you feeling we're looking at the
replays right now you're like an inch
away that last one
i mean i feel good about it but i still
i feel a little disappointed a little
bit of time yeah i mean i swear that
went right through your head and the
glove uh there's part of me that's okay
that you didn't bust up the face it's a
big day it's a big day bunts went up
throwing accuracy now at 90
mlb the show you have a message for all
the gamers out there that are thinking
about using you well if you want to lay
down a bun a big situation i got you
and i'm gonna make my place for you guys
i promise you're the man yeah i
appreciate you both appreciate you man
i don't like that you smashed my face
but i did find it entertaining so that
was good that was awesome
you